here on the YouTube stage at PAX Prime
2015 we are about to take a look at not
one not two but three excellent games
all wrapped up into one pretty little
package for you courtesy the folks at
Naughty Dog one of those guys have
joined me right now Eric hello hey Chris
hi man I uncharted collection yeah man
you guys taking those uncharted games
assorted the main ps3 classics yeah slam
him all together making him look real
nice yeah they didn't already look real
nice I mean how much wiggle room do you
guys really have it was pretty
incredible we actually partnered with
blue point games down in Austin so they
took the UH press over and you know
they'd actually blew it out it was
pretty incredible to see like you go
back to uncharted one and you're like
okay this was 2007 that was a little
little shaky ur time yeah we're ears on
from there now see a difference oh yeah
it's almost like you know and a lot of
the things they were able to do to with
our you know the ps4 now they could take
our cinematic models and those cinematic
models became the gameplay models for
this and they were able to tweak them
even more so like the character the
faces and like how they look it's really
crisp it's fantastic and of course like
the facial expressions of characters and
uncharted superkian such a such a big
part of expressing the individuality of
these awesome characters to pull these
adventures together yeah that story and
sort of that emotive effect we want you
to like connect with the characters
every time you're playing the game so it
brings that on and makes you you know
know what's up so here's our boy
Nathaniel give a bruising and going for
a nice pleasant Sunday dry
war-torn bet guys with a cave Nepal oh
yeah I think it literally just said that
on yeah hi so this is right in uncharted
two and a little bit of the ways into
the game but things are about to go bad
for our boy as they took the fancy he's
got a quick liberty for getting in the
situation alright you got it so what
like you know obviously like these are
games of people know and love for for
many years across like many different
adventures I would looks like cool up
for you about having this project about
bringing these games like sort of up to
speed and remastering it amazed
just I mean this was this game
especially on 32 was the reason like I
even wanted to apply to work at Naughty
Dog it was like one of those games I
played and I played it and I was like
you know I got up to i think level 61 or
62 and multi-player wow that was just
into it I was crushing it I beat it on
crushing it is honestly the only game
I've ever Platinum's oh really so it's
one of those games it's like super dear
to my heart it is I think I can't claim
to have platinum did but it's like you
play that game you play this game
through and there's just so many moments
that just astound you and excite you and
are just so fit like so best in class
yeah that it's yeah it's one of the
all-time greats for sure you go moment
to moment in this game 2 and this is so
much about that drops her jaw and you're
like how did they do that at that time
especially when I was on the outside
looking in at the fan I was like I don't
know how any developer was good enough
with that map can you possibly what
magical organizations could pull this
thing together yeah that's a pretty good
organization to go to work for ya yeah
it ended up working out it's pretty
awesome alright so you did mention
multiplayer in your own experience but
there's not multiplayer coming back into
the collection yeah correct correct well
we have multiplayer in the form of
uncharted 4 beta okay yeah so what we
thought and it really it sounds weird
but 2009 you know when this game came
out people are still playing uncharted
two even and then 2011 when uncharted 3
came out people are still playing
multiplayer on that so we were looking
at that in these communities I still get
a couple videos every week some like
uncharted 3
they're like oh yeah it's uncharted TV
can we put this in the game and I'm like
all right we don't want to like fracture
those communities and tell everybody now
like Joe play on ps4 we were like all
right what's the next best thing we're
gonna give them guns ready for
multiplayer beta the Uncharted or multi
player beta that's like that's next year
sometime you guys have a date on that
yeah we don't have a date quite yet but
we're gonna be releasing some info about
it really soon all right so it's the
single player experience here of course
that's like what a desolate that one of
the best things about it I feel good but
my experience you know in terms of the
gameplay mechanics it does evolve over
the course of these three games so and
this i think was an interesting thing to
sort of play you know sort of play the
recent Gears of War you know enhanced it
or update Ultimate Edition seeing what
lessons they took from later games and
put applied to that game so like where
are you guys pinning down sort of the
the movement the grenade throws the
aiming from across those three games yes
so we looked at was sort of you know one
of the biggest issues that came up was
the aiming and uncharted 3 when that
came out and we look how that function
still and we're like all right when did
we actually get aiming right when was it
like the sweet spot with it and blue
point even did a little bit more
research you know we've been playing
this game for what like eight years now
like I'd be different Gator so we
figured out what the best sort of aiming
mechanics were and we tried to apply it
a class all three of these titles so you
sort of feel get a different feel for
the game and it feel like something new
and it's running now at 1080p and this
really high frame rate so it plays quite
differently now do you ever you ever
have these moments where you go back and
you look at it through you know 1080p
running running real quick on the frame
rate there are moments works like it
looks to you later like the frames are
too fast cuz like that that's a thing
if your frame rates not in balance with
the experience right you know the bigger
number is not always the better number
yeah and I mean that's that's something
we pride ourselves on so we did a lot of
you know tweaking with this to make sure
it looks good one of the most remarkable
things is we have some sort of you know
if you look at some of these buildings
in the background if you go back to the
old ps3 game sort of looks like a brown
square on top of you know like is the
draw distance you couldn't draw things
in the background but now like vicks
coming up on here in the back to smoke
you seeing everything you know you see
up the details and the textures on
everything it's really remarkable you
know that's that's one of the biggest
thing I noticed other and it's yet
uncharted has always been a series where
the environmental design is so good and
so rich that multiple times per level i
find myself you know like i'm in a dire
situation like guys are trying to kill
me like it's a pretty high stakes but
I'm like just standing around like
golfing things like oh my god those
plants are so great so fit the painting
on this mural that's like half faded and
this ruin is so good yeah I mean like
even a little bit like skull here
incredible our environment and our
artist teams are remarkable on how
meticulous there with all the details to
everything and
you know even going back and looking at
some of this to like oh wow now at this
resolution that's how I wanted it to
look give me that like it it's awesome
to just sort of like see it almost
become like the ultimate vision of what
they had in mind and that's cool you
know from an artist perspective to get
to see your sort of your work brought to
life in a slightly different way or
maybe realize it in a more true vision
of what you had originally imagined do
you guys have any of those kind of like
I don't know like reactions or any kind
of extra content in terms of like the
development side or uncharted history is
the collection yeah so I mean there's
there's we're gonna be doing some we're
gonna get the developers on camera we're
gonna do some live streams and have them
play through this we've had a few
developers in our studio you know look
at the collection they're like wow I you
know I forgot we even put this or the
games really fun at the time for that on
that we should have changed that bad
like it still looks bad but we'll make
it work so you know one of those
things it's just great to hear those
reactions then what we're going to do is
we're going to have them get on camera
get on live stream and just sort of walk
through like the times that they did
they made Nepal level they made whatever
level and that sort of thing all right
so like follow Naughty Dog on Twitter or
somebody at a bodega leave and I on that
stuff yeah cool you mentioned sort of
you know oh we maybe shouldn't have done
it that way did you guys do any tweaks
about stuff that you maybe should be
doing any little things to sort of yeah
help yourselves a little bit to help the
player out well it's crazy because when
you get up to the higher resolution
especially with uncharted one like you
know back with lower lower Lear
polycount and lower resolution you can
sort of fudge stuff with the lighting
and sort of you hid stuff from you you
angled it away but we actually went down
the Blue Point and they did a
playthrough of each of the games but we
sort of SAT there and we're like all
right that flood light or that spotlight
you can see it looks like flat right now
like we got to figure out how to tweak
that lighting so it's more dynamic and
it sort of fits into everything though
there was a ton of stuff that was done
like that and it's it's pretty
incredible to feed like those changes
being made as we play through the game
now very cool kind of a surreal
experience for you as a once uncharted
fan now a nunchuck while still in a
chart oh and right man yeah now a guy
was you know his hands on the Uncharted
collection which is coming out in just a
month or two now yeah October 9th it'll
hit stores and it's going to be
remarkable I'm excited for people to get
in their hands especially this is whole
new generation of players that have may
have never even you know own the ps3 to
play it so now you can check it out on
your ps4 get their hands on it and then
they're going to get there you know dip
their toes in the uncharted 4 beta which
is going to be awesome the multiplayer
beta come in sometime next year and
comes up coming sometime coming sometime
soon we're gonna give a day very soon
about it all right announcement comes
soon on that and then uncharted 4
announcements coming soon on that
absolutely Lea like like maybe now soon
okay probably no no no no all right now
Eric thank you so much Matt going on I'm
short a collection earth looking
excellent folks for all the Uncharted
collection hotness you gotta check out
gaming dot YouTube
calm / gamespot and we'll be sure to
keep you guys updated as always we back
with guitar hero live just a few minutes
you